uh i mean it seems like every game we
play
we're battling um
just some some things that the game flow
can
sometimes bring you you know whether it
be some calls going your way whether it
be some high scoring
quarters they score 48 in the fourth
quarter i don't know if we're gonna get
many wins if we
allow 48 points in any quarter so um you
know it's a tough night when you're
giving up that many points and it's a
tough night when you
you know you're not particularly
you know doing the little things that
could create some separation
you know down the stretch we we had that
game it should have been ours so
you know we just look at ourselves in
the mirror and just see where we can
correct
as individuals and as a group you know
just especially on the effort you know i
i couldn't guard a stick today
you know those guys were just going
right around me and you know i was
getting frustrated a little bit but they
kept attacking and that's what good
teams doing good scorers do
if so if you could take us in the locker
room what's the communication like
amongst teammates when again there are
struggles defensively
some miscues down the stretch there's a
lot of veterans in that locker room
what's the communication like as you
refocus well number one is just
reminding joe harris and
tlc that stuff happens and it's not
their fault you know that was just a
microcosm of what the game was was like
tonight you know we had the lead
we were pretty comfortable uh and then
down the stretch
we just still got to be hungry until
zero's on the clock and
as you saw washington was very desperate
um
and we expected him to play well tonight
you know any time the team goes up
against us we expect him to start
hitting things that
you know you gotta give respect but at
the same time it's going against a good
brooklyn nets team
so we just take this one on the chin and
keep it moving
greg logan with newsday uh kyrie
72 points in the paint that you guys
gave up
uh you know you're you're undersized a
little
bit you lost a lot of size in in the
trade
do you think that that's a a persistent
issue
that needs to be addressed uh somewhere
going down the line in this season
uh we'll see we'll see like i said we
have the group that we have in our
locker room right now i'm grateful to be
playing every day with them and you know
though we'll allow the outsiders say
we're under size we we believe that we
we should be
you know winning every single game based
upon our effort and based on uh you know
our offensive offensive
firepower so you know obviously the eye
test
you know we're not necessarily passing
it in terms of having all the the
big guys in the lead but like i said we
just got to match other teams effort and
we've been doing that lately
and you know successful road trip and
now we get back home and play against a
good clippers team
ryan lewis with the new york post hey
curry i mean you kind of
alluded to it uh but i mean obviously
when you're up 18 at any point and five
with 12 seconds left you would think you
would win that game but
do you think that kind of thought
process crept in earlier
than it should have like maybe you guys
had it in your brain okay this
we've got this assaulted away well i
can't i can't speak for everybody in the
group
uh you know particularly what they're
thinking but i could say that you know
down the stretch that's that's
where we really really got to make our
mark and we usually do
and tonight like i said stuff happens
and we got to take this one on the chin
it's no one's fault if anything
you know we individually take our own
efforts where we can be better and then
we move forward
malinka andrews with espn are you
one how are you assessing that last
sequence um
bradley beal hitting the three the
inbound past deal and then that three
from russell westbrook and then secondly
are you looking at that as the culprit
of this loss or was it a more of a we
shouldn't have been in that position and
you're kind of looking at the
breakdowns before that like like i said
it was a microcosm of the night
and i would never put blame on anybody
you know
not one person can can take you know one
play
that could dictate the game you know we
were we were up by five
and we lost the game um and and that's
okay you know like i said stuff happens
but we cannot continue
to make a habit out of late game
situations
and not being um you know aware of the
execution we need down the stretch so
it's a tough one it's a double invite on
chain because we definitely like you
said we definitely had
the lead down the stretch and we want to
finish that strong but it's okay